- You might recognize Rachel Powell
as the woman who participated
in the January 6th riots,
and then when the judge ordered her
to wear a mask pending
her release from prison,
she defied that by wearing a
mask that was nothing but mesh,
in clear defiance of the judge's wishes.
- Good morning, everybody.
Welcome to Mr. Bookman's page.
- But not surprising, when
she posted these photos
to social media, the judge issued an OSC
in order to show cause
why he shouldn't bring
the hammer down on her
for her obvious defiance of his order.
Well not surprisingly, Rachel
Powell apologized to the judge
and said that, well, she was misguided
by Lana Del Ray who had
some sort of clear mask.
Sorry about that, judge.
You really just can't make any of this up,
which is why I'll probably
see her and you in court.